But there's one thing that just about every dog does: bark.
So why do they bark?
Where does it come from?
Wolves don't bark.
They howl.
Some scientists think that barking has evolved just for our benefit.
So does this mean that they're talking to us?
And if so, what are they saying?
They seem to understand our words.
Dig, dig.
Come on, speak.
Good boy.
But can dogs really talk to us by barking?
I don't think anybody ever understands dogs.
They understand you.
I don't think you'll ever understand a dog.
It's been identified that dogs can communicate...
...at least six different emotions to us through their barks.
That's why I know what you're thinking.
That just proves, doesn't it, that dogs can talk by barking.